one more question here from Eduardo in
Brooklyn I started to do well in the
corporate world and I make good money
but I'm seeking more meaning and
fulfillment I've always wanted to pursue
graphic design what advice do you have
for someone who's trying to step away
from the comfort of financial success
and what does you guys take when living
your jobs to get by financially I will
say this when I this was the time when
the budget was most important to me I
left the corporate world I made twenty
three thousand dollars that year or the
year I left and I was strangely more
financially free because I had my my
spending under control now it took it
really it took more of a shift in
mindset realizing like oh I didn't need
these things I didn't actually enjoy the
things I was bringing into my life in
fact they brought in all these negative
consequences stress debt anxiety and
made me feel that way about money and so
in a strange way I was actually
contributing more making twenty three
thousand dollars a year not just to my
own retirement but I was contributing
more to the community because I had
freed up my time my other resources
which are equally if not more important
this is the this shows you the power of
mindset and I I'm not really whoo-whoo
if anything you can tell I could sit
here and talk for three hours about
asset allocation and Vanguard research
but last night we met a woman who was
there and she said that for years she
had been in debt for years her husband's
a CPA her husband had been telling her
we got to pay off this debt etc but it
wasn't until they decided they wanted to
buy a house in LA and she saw how much
it cost and she wanted that house that
she said he didn't want I'm gonna start
paying this off and I asked her last
night I said would you have changed for
anything else if somebody gave you this
advice four years ago would you have
changed she's like my husband gave me
that advice all the time I didn't listen
I wasn't ready and so your example is
perfect because you as you said save
more were contributing more meaningfully
to your community on 23000 than on six
figures now imagine if you're as mindful
at
as you were at 23 it amplifies the good
this is exactly so for everyone
listening you have to find your why you
have to find your reason and it could be
buying a house it could be we're having
a kid it could be I want to leave my
unfulfilled job and go into graphic
design I will share a few tools that I
used for this as well first of all I
know what it's like to make a little bit
of money because when I graduated I was
gonna go work at Google I decided not to
I decided to do a tech startup I made
$11,000 that year and I still had a lot
of friends working at Google so I'd go
eat there I would take my backpack and
fill it up with popcorn and free food
okay so so in the eyes of the average
Stan you went Stanford right you're the
average Stanford graduate you might have
been looking at yourself like oh what am
i doing I should have done the Google
thing 100% I mean I was really torn and
first of all these are first class first
world problems I should I go to Google
or should I work on my own startup but
the startup didn't make money so that's
important to know but I had the freedom
and flexibility at very low expenses I
was living in a shared house with three
or four other guys and my rent was like
eight hundred bucks a month in Mountain
View which is good and I knew I had
confidence in myself that I'll make this
work or I can always go back and get
another job okay so there was that I
will say that when I finally that the
startup took off and I was thinking
about should I go full-time on I will
teach you to be rich and I basically
created a simple formula for myself and
that was I was doing I will teach on the
side I had my full-time income and I
said I'm not even gonna think about
leaving until I make more through I will
teach you to be rich three months in a
row not once and that happened once
twice and I was like oh it's about to
happen
nope go back to zero so it forced me to
recognize that it wasn't a fluke that
there was something here and it had to
be consecutive now you might say look
I'm just starting off my graphic design
thing I can't hope to equal what I
currently make in any reasonable amount
of time fine make it 50% make it
whatever it is that is meaningful to you
that you're not going to go from let's
say making 120 thousand dollars to zero
because that's a very sudden stop
rather have you go a little bit gradual
and have the formula that works for
yourself but when it comes to your money
I like to be realistic I like to be
conservative but I also like to leave
room for big growth yeah the only thing
I would add to that is I wouldn't leave
until your debt free so make sure that
you're debt-free but because that that
debt is an anchor for you so not only do
you have the anchor of the career that
you don't find meaningful which by the
way the last thing I guess I could say
here is you can find meaning in whatever
you're doing you might be working at a
gas station pumping gas that well I
guess you gonna do that New Jersey now
but if you're doing that you can find
great meaning in that meaning only
exists because we impart it onto
something there is not an intrinsic
meaning in this glass of water all right
and and so when we're talking about
meaning maybe you can temporarily find
what is meaningful about the work you
are doing the customers you're serving
the problems you're solving I'm so glad
you said that because I don't want
anyone to mistake the idea that if you
suddenly become an entrepreneur you're
gonna have meaning that is not true
you will have to find meaning there just
as you have to find meaning in your job
I also don't want people to mistake that
if I double my income it's going to be
meaningful no it's not until you find
meaning where you are today you will not
find meaning in the next place you go
you